This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When people ask us where we get our stories from, the answer is usually hard to pen down. It could be something one of us noticed walking around, or something a friend mentioned, or some forwarded link on Twitter. It's nearly impossible to say where inspiration comes from in any art form. It's a long way from the seed of an idea to its execution. The brilliant architect, Oliver Alto, put it very well in an extended metaphor about
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。当人们问我们从哪里获取故事灵感时，答案通常很难界定。它可能源于我们某人在散步时的偶然发现，或是朋友随口提到的一件事，又或是推特上转发的某个链接。在任何艺术形式中，几乎都无法说清灵感究竟从何而来。从一个创意的萌芽到最终的实现，是一段漫长的旅程。杰出的建筑师阿尔瓦·阿尔托曾用一个延伸的比喻，非常贴切地描述了这一点：
a fish in a stream. He wrote, Architecture and its details are in some way all part of biology. Perhaps they are, for instance, like some big salmon or trout. They're not born fully grown. They're not even born in the sea or water where they normally live. They are born hundreds of miles away from their home grounds, where the rivers narrow to tiny streams.
一条溪流中的鱼。他写道：“建筑及其细节在某种程度上都是生物学的一部分。也许它们就像某种大马哈鱼或鳟鱼。它们并非生来就已完全长成。它们甚至不是出生在它们通常生活的海洋或水域中。它们出生在距离家园数百英里远的地方，那里河流汇聚成细小的溪流。”
Just as it takes time for us to spec a fish pond to mature into a fully grown fish, so we need time for everything that develops and crystallizes in our world of ideas. This is a story about one idea born hundreds of miles away in a far off stream, an idea that would travel from northern Europe to southern California, where it would take on a whole new life before making its way back again. It's a story in three parts by producer Avery Truffleman. Part one, California. Two skaters in a plaza are confronted by a guard.
正如鱼卵发育成一条成熟的鱼需要时间一样，我们世界中所有发展和结晶的创意也需要时间。这是一个关于一个创意在数百英里外的遥远溪流中诞生的故事，这个创意从北欧一路传到南加州，在那里焕发了全新的生命，随后又回到了起点。这是由制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼带来的三部分系列报道。第一部分：加利福尼亚。广场上的两名滑板手被保安拦住了。
Can't skate here? Oh, man, it looks so good. Just one broken leg, please. Can't skate here? Oh, man, it looks so good. Just one broken leg, please. It's kind of a pity that skateboarding is banned in so many places, because skateboarders appreciate the small details of architecture more than anyone. They recognize the quality of concrete, the grain of wood, the incline of a structure. They recognize the way a landscape flows.
“不能在这里滑板吗？噢，伙计，这看起来太棒了。就让我滑一次吧，哪怕摔断腿也行。”“不能在这里滑板吗？噢，伙计，这看起来太棒了。就让我滑一次吧，哪怕摔断腿也行。”滑板在许多地方被禁止，这真是一种遗憾，因为滑板手比任何人都更能欣赏建筑的细微之处。他们能识别混凝土的质感、木材的纹理、建筑的坡度。他们能识别景观流动的韵律。
Masked to start by introducing yourself? My name is Jake Phelps, I'm the editor of Thrasher Magazine from San Francisco, California, born and raised. Yeah, what do you got? Thrasher is a skateboarding magazine that skaters call the Bible. Visiting its headquarters is kind of surreal. It's like if you went to a skate park
“能先做个自我介绍吗？”“我叫杰克·菲尔普斯，我是来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的《Thrasher》杂志编辑，土生土长。没错，你想问什么？”《Thrasher》是一本被滑板手称为“圣经”的滑板杂志。参观它的总部感觉有点超现实。就像你走进一个滑板公园，
and yelled out to all the punks, Hey, you guys want to go hang out in an office? They're all there, and sneakers and beanie caps, slumped behind monitors like caged animals. You can tell they'd rather be skating. I'm a skater, I dress like a skater. These are the costumes I've been running all my life. I don't wear a fucking Louis Vuitton clothes,
然后对着所有的朋克大喊：“嘿，你们想去办公室待着吗？”他们都在那儿，穿着运动鞋，戴着针织帽，像笼中动物一样瘫在显示器后面。你能看出他们宁愿去滑板。我是个滑板手，我的穿着也像个滑板手。这些是我一生都在穿的“戏服”。我才不穿那些该死的路易威登衣服，
and I'm doing that worst sneakers. And this is the way it is. We're utilitarian, we skate. It's the greatest thing in the world. Jake Phelps is 55 years old. Tattoos, all over his arms. Big thick glasses of his face and close cropped gray hair.
我穿的是最破烂的运动鞋。事实就是这样。我们是实用主义者，我们滑板。这是世界上最棒的事情。杰克·菲尔普斯今年55岁。双臂布满纹身。脸上戴着一副厚重的大眼镜，留着修剪得很短的灰发。
He blatantly hits on me in the interview and invites me to his punk band show over the weekend. I don't think he'd mind that I told you that. skateboarding never says no. Girlfriends, jobs, life. People always say no, I can't do that. I've been doing this for 40 years. You can't tell me I can't do it.
他在采访中公然调戏我，还邀请我周末去参加他的朋克乐队演出。我想他不会介意我把这事说出来。“滑板从不说不。女朋友、工作、生活。人们总是说‘不，我做不到’。我已经滑了40年了。你不能告诉我我做不到。”
Fuck you. Say the fuck away from me. skateboarding is, you know, it's like an extension of me. It's like it's an art. It's like, it's an art. It's something that you have to understand. So where does the artistry come in? It's your whole Jouat-e-V. How you hold yourself.
“去你的。离我远点。”“滑板，你知道，它就像是我身体的延伸。它是一种艺术。它就是一种艺术。这是你必须去理解的东西。”那么艺术性体现在哪里呢？体现在你的整个姿态（Je ne sais quoi）。你如何掌控自己。
And that Jouat-e-Vue, that sort of badass, double-may-care attitude that skaters have perfected. That's kind of funny because skateboarding was pretty dorky back when it was just getting started. The very first skateboard was called the skateboard scooter, and it was a scooter. This is Stacey Peralta, skateboarding pioneer and director of the excellent documentary Dogtown and Z-Boys, which is all about the birth of modern skateboarding. Stacey says at some point no one really knows when, but someone knocked the handlebars off the scooter
那种“Je ne sais quoi”，那种滑板手们所完善的玩世不恭、无所畏惧的态度。这其实挺有趣的，因为滑板刚开始的时候其实很傻。第一个滑板被称为“滑板滑板车”，它确实就是个滑板车。这是斯泰西·佩拉尔塔，滑板先驱，也是那部关于现代滑板运动诞生的优秀纪录片《狗镇和滑板少年》的导演。斯泰西说，在某个时间点——没人知道具体是什么时候——有人把滑板车的车把拆掉了，
and just rode the board. And probably emulated surfing. And so what happened was, skateboarding had a very, very brief appearance in 1964 and 65. Skateboards were sold in toy stores, and skateboarding briefly became a fad. But then as quickly as it started,
然后直接踩在板上滑行。可能是在模仿冲浪。于是，滑板运动在1964年和1965年有过非常短暂的露面。滑板在玩具店里出售，滑板运动短暂地成为了一种时尚。但它消失得和出现时一样快，
it died out again. It was like the Hula hoop. It has come and gone. As the skateboard fad was receding into the distance, Stacey was growing up in Venice Beach, California. It was the early 70s, and Stacey was a little surf rat with long blonde hair. And when the waves were bad in the middle of the day, he and his friends wanted something to do. What we really wanted to do was emulate surfing.
它又消亡了。就像呼啦圈一样。来去匆匆。当滑板热潮逐渐远去时，斯泰西正在加利福尼亚州的威尼斯海滩长大。那是70年代初，斯泰西是个留着金色长发的小冲浪迷。当白天海浪不好时，他和朋友们想找点事做。我们真正想做的是模仿冲浪。
They wanted to surf on land. And they discovered old skateboards. One of my friends, his older brothers, had skateboarded in the very early 60s. And they had two skateboards left in their garage that they never touched. So we started riding those boards. Those early skateboards had these hard clunky wheels made out of clay or steel.
他们想在陆地上冲浪。于是他们发现了旧滑板。我朋友的哥哥们在60年代初玩过滑板。他们的车库里还剩下两个滑板，从来没动过。于是我们开始玩那些板子。那些早期的滑板轮子又硬又笨重，是用粘土或钢材做的。
So you'd eat dirt if you ran over a pebble or a penny on the ground. And that meant tricks had to be very simple, like I can stand up straight, or I can balance on the tip of the board. Maybe a wheelie. You could just kind of scoot back and forth on a flat, smooth surface. It's flat land tricks. That's basically what you could do. Stacey was really young, like maybe seven years old.
所以如果你压到地上的小石子或硬币，你就会摔个狗吃屎。这意味着动作必须非常简单，比如我可以站直，或者在板尖上保持平衡。也许做一个翘板动作。你只能在平坦光滑的表面上滑来滑去。基本上只能做些平地动作。斯泰西当时真的很小，大概七岁。
But you can remember skating for the first time. Even with those big clunky clay wheels, Little Stacey found a blissful stillness. It was so profound that from that point forward, I needed to get back on that board and find that stillness because I'm more relaxed when I stand on a skateboard than I am when I walk. But Stacey and his friends were discovering skateboards Well, the rest of the country was forgetting them Stacey had that old board heat on earth than his friends garage, but after I wore that out
但他还记得第一次滑板的情景。即使踩着那些笨重的粘土轮子，小斯泰西也找到了一种幸福的宁静。这种感觉太深刻了，从那时起，我就需要回到板上寻找那种宁静，因为站在滑板上比走路时更让我放松。但当斯泰西和朋友们发现滑板时，全国其他地方却正在遗忘它。斯泰西有那个在朋友车库里找到的旧板，但在我把它滑坏之后，
There was no more boards to see, you know, that I could buy in stores It just you couldn't buy a skateboard back then. So instead there's no more boards to see, you know, that I could buy in stores. It just, you couldn't buy a skateboard back then. So instead, Stacey and his friends would go to a thrift store and buy a pair of roller skates, which had clay or metal or hard plastic wheels. And maybe Stacey would take the left skate
就再也找不到板子了，你知道，商店里根本买不到。当时你根本买不到滑板。所以，斯泰西和他的朋友们会去旧货店买一双旱冰鞋，上面有粘土、金属或硬塑料轮子。也许斯泰西会拿走左边的鞋，
and his friend would take the right skate and they'd cut the bases off the wheels and put them on a plank of wood and then ride that back and forth and back and forth and back and forth and back and forth for hours. And the hours that we spent doing it would be equivalent to a kid today, you know, jumping up and down for eight hours on a pogo stick, you know, every single day, seven days a week,
他的朋友拿走右边的鞋，他们把轮子底座拆下来，装在一块木板上，然后滑来滑去，滑来滑去，滑来滑去，一滑就是几个小时。我们花在上面的时间，相当于现在的孩子每天在弹簧高跷上跳来跳去八个小时，你知道，一周七天，天天如此。
and you'd probably go, geez, maybe we should tell this kid that there's no future in this. Then in the early 70s, an invention comes along that would revolutionize skateboarding, the year-arethane wheel. This soft plastic wheel had more give to it and held the ground, unlike those clunky, dangerous clay wheels that preceded it. These soft wheels were intended for roller skaters at the dawn of the roller disco era, but a small company called Creative Yerathanes
你可能会说：“天哪，也许我们该告诉这孩子，这没前途。”然后，在70年代初，一项发明彻底改变了滑板运动：聚氨酯轮。这种软塑料轮子更有弹性，抓地力更好，不像之前那些笨重危险的粘土轮子。这些软轮最初是为旱冰鞋设计的，正值旱冰迪斯科时代，但一家名为“创意聚氨酯”的小公司
began producing urethane wheels specifically for skateboarding. Put the board together back there and then up put the wheels on a feral thing. The wheels were sold at surf shops since there were no skate shops and they were advertised in surfer magazine. 58.46 altogether. And in the summer of 1974, sales of urethane wheels went gangbusters. Suddenly we had a wheel that could grip and it could roll over bumps in little rocks and it allowed us to attack terrain that previously were not we were not able to
开始专门生产用于滑板的聚氨酯轮。把板子组装好，然后装上聚氨酯轮。轮子在冲浪店出售，因为当时没有滑板店，它们还在《冲浪者》杂志上做广告。总共58.46美元。1974年的夏天，聚氨酯轮的销量火爆。突然间，我们有了一种可以抓地、可以碾过颠簸和小石头的轮子，它让我们能够挑战以前无法挑战的地形。
attack. Now they could skate all surfaces. Greater Los Angeles was theirs to claim. And so that meant school yards that meant in garages, city buildings, it was any place. Anything was rideable, but none of this was designed for us, none of them. These young kids were jumping fences and trespassing and breaking things. All in search of new surfaces to ride, they were reinterpreting the city around them, finding the beauty, and the pavement, and the concrete of their world. And then, in the mid-70s, there was a drought in California. In Southern California, the driest part of the state. There have been dozens of brush fires.
现在他们可以滑行在任何表面上。大洛杉矶地区成了他们的领地。这意味着学校操场、车库、市政建筑，任何地方都可以。任何东西都可以滑，但这些地方都不是为我们设计的。这些年轻人翻越围栏、擅闯私人领地、破坏公物。他们都在寻找新的滑行表面，他们重新诠释了周围的城市，发现了他们世界中路面和混凝土的美感。然后，在70年代中期，加利福尼亚发生了干旱。在南加州，这个州最干旱的地区，发生了几十起灌木丛火灾。
Some have been big and expensive. And more fires were threatened, as Californians crave for rain. But right now, the workers say not as expected. The drought was so bad in the 70s that the water company ran billboard ads that encouraged couples to shower together to save water. And to further save water,
有些火灾规模很大，损失惨重。随着加州人对雨水的渴望，更多的火灾威胁接踵而至。但目前，工作人员表示情况并不乐观。70年代的干旱非常严重，自来水公司甚至打出广告，鼓励夫妻一起洗澡以节约用水。为了进一步节水，
people didn't fill up their swimming pools. And in Los Angeles, there are a lot of swimming pools and they're very distinctive looking. What we had in Los Angeles is we had the big, beautiful, voluptuous shapes that you did not see anywhere else in the world that you find in Los Angeles, except in very, very, very, very small quantities. The pools of Los Angeles are shaped like peanuts, like keyholes, like kidney beans. They have these curved, unrelating edges.
人们不再往游泳池里注水。在洛杉矶，有很多游泳池，而且它们看起来非常有特色。我们在洛杉矶拥有的是那些巨大、美丽、丰满的形状，你在世界其他任何地方都看不到，除非数量极少。洛杉矶的游泳池形状像花生、像锁孔、像腰果。它们有着弯曲、起伏的边缘。
They are paved in even smooth concrete with gently varying rounded depths that slope back up to the lip. And during the drought in the 70s, they were all empty. They were perfect. They just were so beautifully conceived and designed and um, we fell in love with the shapes.
它们铺着平整光滑的混凝土，有着逐渐变化的圆润深度，坡度向上延伸至池边。在70年代的干旱期间，它们全都干涸了。它们太完美了。它们的设计构思如此精美，我们爱上了这些形状。
Stacey and his friends would hunt for pools. They'd find a house under construction or patrol the fancy parts of town where they knew they'd find the most sumptuous, luxurious pools. Tony! They'd hopped a fence, they'd break in. We'll bail and we'll look it up to you guys. If there's a little bit of old dirty water in the pool, they'd break in. Well, failed, we'll look it up to you guys. If there's a little bit of old dirty water in the pool, they'd drain it out themselves with buckets they brought
斯泰西和他的朋友们会四处寻找游泳池。他们会找到正在施工的房子，或者在城里的高档区域巡逻，因为他们知道那里有最豪华、最奢华的游泳池。“托尼！”他们会翻过围栏，闯进去。“我们会把水抽干，然后告诉你们。”如果池子里有一点脏水，他们会自己动手，用带来的桶
or trash cans they found, or eventually, they'd bring an industrial vacuum along with them. And then they would skate up and down in the pool. They'd go so fast they could go up the wall. They could skate like they were surfing away. When we finally got to ride swimming pools and feel weightless, like going up a vertical wall, weightlessness is pretty extraordinary. Skateboarding became a form of choreography, where you're trying to do as much as possible
或者找到的垃圾桶，或者最终，他们会带上一台工业真空吸尘器。然后他们会在池子里滑来滑去。他们滑得飞快，甚至能冲上池壁。他们滑起来就像在冲浪一样。当我们最终能在游泳池里滑行，感受到失重感，就像冲上垂直的墙壁一样，那种失重感真是太非凡了。滑板变成了一种编舞，你试图在有限的池内空间里做尽可能多的动作，并保持优雅。我们是一群衣衫褴褛的孩子，我们在后院的游泳池里滑行，我们知道我们所做的是美丽的，我们能感受到这种美。这种美吸引了人们的注意。早在60年代初的第一波滑板热潮中，就有一本名为《滑板手》的杂志。当滑板热潮消退时，它倒闭了。但在70年代中期，这本杂志又回来了。它刊登了斯泰西和他的朋友们在后院游泳池里滑行的照片。那时，美国的每个孩子
in the limited space of the pool and look graceful while doing it. Here we were a bunch of scruffy kids and here we are riding in backyard pools and we know what we're doing is beautiful and we get to feel beautiful. And this beauty attracted attention. Back in the first wave of skateboarding in the early 60s there had been a magazine called Simply Skateboarder. It went out of business when the skateboarding fad died out. But in the mid 70s, the magazine came back. And it featured Stacey and his friends, riding in backyard pools. At that point, every kid in America
乃至全世界的孩子都想钻进游泳池里。就是这样。那是圣杯。所以，干旱确实成为了滑板革命的绝佳助产士。最终，斯泰西和其他滑板手在池中滑行的技术变得如此高超，以至于他们能够滑出池边。他们可以跳到空中，在落回池子之前做个旋转之类的动作。
and all over the world wanted to get inside a swimming pool. That was it. That was the Holy Grail. And so the drought really acted as a wonderful midwife to the skateboarding revolution. Eventually, Stacey and the other skateboarders got so good at pool skating, they were able to skate up over the edge of the pool. They could kind of jump up in the air and maybe do a spin or something before dropping back into the pool.
这些空中动作引出了滑板运动的另一个流派。于是，风格变得不那么重要，极限动作变得更加重要。空中动作为X运动会、U型池和托尼·霍克铺平了道路。这是这项运动的整个篇章，滑板手们试图将自己弹射到极高的地方。这一切都可以追溯到洛杉矶那些圆润的仿生游泳池。那些形状像花生、锁孔和腰果的池子。洛杉矶是后院游泳池的麦加，不仅是后院游泳池的麦加，更是设计精美、恰到好处的后院游泳池的麦加。
And these aerial tricks led to another genre of skateboarding. So style became less important and extreme maneuvers became more important. Ariel tricks paved the way for the X games, half pipes and Tony Hawk. This whole chapter of the sport where skaters were trying to vault themselves really, really high up in the air. And that can all be traced back to the rounded biomorphic pools of Los Angeles. The ones shaped like peanuts and keyholes and kidney beans. LA was the backyard pool mecca, but not just the backyard pool mecca, the properly beautifully designed backyard pool.
我不知道世界上还有哪个地方拥有如此多那种丰满、感性的设计。南加州游泳池的普及导致了滑板运动的普及。现在滑板的人比以往任何时候都多。这是一个价值70亿美元的产业。“该死。”又是《Thrasher》的杰克·菲尔普斯。人们每天都在池子里滑板。人们现在就在滑。
And I don't know of any place in the world that has that proliferation of that kind of voluptuous, sensuous design. The pools of Southern California and their proliferation led to the proliferation of skating. More people are skateboarding now than ever. It's a $7 billion industry. Goddamn. That's Jake Phelps at Thrashere again. People are skating pools every day. People are skating right now.
肯定有人现在就在池子里摔断了胳膊。相信我。加州的游泳池把我们带到了下一个篇章。你知道腰果形游泳池的由来吗？“腰果形，什么是腰果形？”“还有那个，亨尼·金尼？那是叫这个吗？”“嗯，是的，它们叫腰果形。我不知道。”
Somebody just broke their arm in a pool right now. Trust me. And the pools of California bring us to our next chapter. Do you know the story about where the bean shape pool comes from? The bean shape, what's the bean shape? And the right, Henny Kinney? Is that what it's called? Well, yeah, they're called bean shape. I don't know.
“好吧，显然这会是某人后院里某种深奥的设计。”好吧，杰克·菲尔普斯没必要表现得那么刻薄，但他说的没错。它确实始于某人后院里一个深奥的设计。但这可能是20世纪美国历史上最著名的私人后院。第二部分：索诺玛。在北加州索诺玛县一个偏远山丘的顶端，在一条孤独的
Well, obviously it would be some esoteric design to someone's backyard. Well, Jake Phelps doesn't have to be all like that about it, but he's right. It starts with one So-Taric design in someone's backyard. But it might be the most famous private backyard in 20th century American history. Part 2. Sonoma On top of a remote hill in Sonoma County in Northern California, at the end of a lone
蜿蜒土路的尽头，车子驶入了一条车道。三只小狗冲出来迎接艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。贾斯汀·法乔尔和桑迪·唐内尔是这处房产的主人和守护者，这里被称为“唐内尔花园”。它在景观建筑界非常有名。但如果你想参观它，那是个挑战。你在谷歌地图上找不到它。地址是错的。也没有任何公开的列表或网站提供联系信息。
curvy dirt road, the car pulls into a driveway. Three small dogs rush out to meet a retruffinist. Justin Faggiole and Sandy Dunnell are the owners and caretakers of this property, which is known as the Dunnell Garden. It's really famous in the world of landscape architecture. But if you want to visit it, it's kind of a challenge. You can't find it on Google Maps. That address is wrong. And there aren't any public listings or sites with contact information for it.
因为它只是一个私人住宅。山丘上一座中等大小、复古现代风格的房子。这是桑迪父母的住所。“我在唐内尔牧场长大，1951年出生，是三个孩子中最小的一个。”唐内尔花园建于1948年，在当时是革命性的。20世纪初的传统花园
Because it's just a private home. A modest sized retro-modernmodern looking house on a hill. It was Sandy's parents' place. My group on the Danelle Ranch property, born in 1951, the youngest of three children. The Danelle Garden was planted in 1948, and it was revolutionary at the time. Traditional gardens of the early 20th century
或多或少都是对称排列的各种花卉。它们就像植物博物馆。也许会点缀着几何形状的树篱或果树。唐内尔花园完全不是那样。它大部分是草坪。草坪是一个统一的特征。它蜿蜒穿过一切，成为了一条河流，一条从空间到空间流动的绿色河流。
had been more or less symmetrical rows of different kinds of flowers. They were kind of like plant museums. of the century had been more or less symmetrical rows of different kinds of flowers. They were kind of like plant museums. May be accented with a geometric hedge or a fruit tree. The Donald Garden is nothing like that. It's mostly lawn. The lawn is a unifying feature. It meanders through everything and it becomes the river, the green river that goes from space
花园看起来像是一片修剪整齐的草海，漂浮着热带植物群岛或岩石群，还有几棵古老的橡树，此外还有大片的混凝土和巨大的木制露台。从上方看，花园就像马蒂斯的拼贴画，在绿色草坪画布上排列着抽象的形状。而最独特的形状，当然是游泳池。“天哪。这就是你要找的目标。”
to space. The garden looks like a sea of clean cut grass, with floating islands of tropical plant clusters or groups of rocks and a few ancient oak trees, and there are large swaths of concrete and a big wooden deck. From above, the garden is almost like a matease collage, an arrangement of abstract shapes on a green grass canvas. And the most distinctive shape, of course, is the pool. Oh my God. Here's the object of your search.
一个腰果形游泳池。据我们所知，这是加州第一个腰果形游泳池。它确实和我预想的一样美。它是明亮、纯净、电光蓝色的。在游泳池中央是阿德琳·肯特的一件抽象雕塑，上面有两个洞，一个在水面上，一个在水下。
A kidney pool. This, from what we know, was the first kidney shaped pool in California. It's every bit as beautiful as I thought, actually. It is bright, pristine, electric blue. And in the center of the pool is an abstract sculpture by Adeline Kent, which has two holes through it, one above water, and one below.
你可以像海豚一样穿过雕塑上的洞，这简直太有趣了。我知道，因为我试过。游泳池俯瞰着数英亩尘土飞扬的牧场。你可以听到远处赛道上汽车的轰鸣声，可以看到旧金山杂乱的天际线在远处朦胧地浮现。我不禁想到，滑板手会为了能把这个池子里的水排干而拼命。它太美了。
And you can swim through the holes in the sculpture like a dolphin, and it's insanely fun. I know because I tried it. because I tried it. The pool overlooks acres of dusty ranching property. You can hear the hum of cars on a racetrack, often the distance, and you can see the Hodgepodge skyline of San Francisco, looming hazeily beyond it. I couldn't help but think that a stator would kill to drain this pool. It's beautiful.
“哇。哇。”很难夸大唐内尔花园对正式景观建筑和日常美国后院的重要性。桑迪·唐内尔告诉我，花园的照片曾被收录在《大英百科全书》的“景观建筑”条目下。这处房产还帮助创造了我们所认为的现代郊区后院，即拥有草坪、露台和游泳池。
Wow. Wow. It's hard to overstate the importance of the Don Al Garden to both formal landscape architecture and everyday American backyards. Sandy Don Al told me that a picture of the garden was Indian cyclopedia Britannica under landscape architecture. The property also helped create what we think of as the modern suburban backyard, with the lawn, the deck, and the pool.
“我猜，除了凡尔赛宫之外，唐内尔花园可能是20世纪出版次数最多的花园。”建筑历史学家马克·特里布说。唐内尔花园由托马斯·丘奇设计，他是一位希望创造人们会使用并喜爱的户外空间的景观建筑师。托马斯·丘奇的书名实际上就是《花园是为人们准备的》。在书中，他问假设的客户：“你到底有多喜欢园艺？”
I would guess, with the exception, possibly, a Versailles, that the Denel Garden was probably the most published garden, at least in the 20th century. Architectural historian Mark Tribe. The Denel Garden was designed by Thomas Church, a landscape architect who wanted to create outdoor spaces that people would use and love. The title of Thomas Church's book was actually, Gardens are for people. In Gardens are for people, he asked hypothetical clients, how much do you really like to garden?
“如果你不想打理花园，你知道，铺装路面很有意义。”丘奇说，花园不一定非要是那些传统的成排花卉。这对像唐内尔一家这样的现代家庭来说是一个启示。他们想要一个聚会、放松和休闲的地方。他们希望他们的院子是一件功能性的艺术品，他们的孩子和狗可以在上面攀爬。唐内尔花园成为了加州户外生活方式的缩影。整个50年代，《日落》和《美好家园》等生活方式杂志都将唐内尔花园作为封面。
If you don't want to garden, you know, the paving makes a lot of sense. Church said that gardens didn't necessarily have to be those traditional rows and rows of flowers. And this was a revelation for modern families like the Donnells. They wanted a place for parties and relaxing and lounging. They wanted their yard to be a piece of functional art that their kids and dogs could clamber on. The Donnell Garden became the epitome of outdoor California lifestyle. Throughout the 1950s, lifestyle magazines, like Sunset and House Beautiful, featured the Donnell Garden on their covers.
在许多方面，它确实成为了美国现代景观建筑的标志。当然，我们来这里很大程度上是因为游泳池。随着唐内尔花园的图像开始传播，南加州各地新晋的郊区居民开始模仿它。西海岸的景观建筑师们受到其对铺装和草坪的创造性运用，以及其美丽的仿生曲线游泳池的启发。这个游泳池启发了成千上万的模仿者，并最终启发了南加州成千上万的年轻滑板手。
In many ways, it became the icon certainly of American modern landscape architecture. A lot of it being, of course, is why we're here for the swimming pool. As images of the Denelgarten began to spread, newly minted suburbanites across Southern California began to imitate it. And West Coast landscape architects were inspired by its creative use of paving and lawn, and its beautiful, biomorphorphic curvy pool. The pool inspired thousands of imitators and eventually thousands of young skaters
现在我们无法确定托马斯·丘奇究竟是从哪里想到了使用最初的腰果形状。复古的回旋镖形状出现在从美术到大规模生产的纺织品和福米卡桌子的所有东西上。到1947年，这些形状随处可见。
in Southern California. Now we can't know for sure exactly where Thomas Church came up with the idea of using the original kidney shape. Retro boomerang shapes were appearing in everything from fine art to mass produced textiles and for myka tables. By 1947ang shapes were appearing in everything from fine art to mass-produced textiles and for micotables. By 1947, these shapes were everywhere.
“你知道，它们出现在所有东西上，随处可见。所以真的很难说。”但关于丘奇从哪里获得腰果形游泳池的灵感，有一个非常有趣且广泛流传的理论。滑板运动在80年代末传到了我的社区。我们从加州场景中得到了一些杂志和视频。第三部分：芬兰。艾弗里·特鲁夫曼真的去了芬兰。
You know, they were on everything and everywhere. So it's really hard to say. But there is a really interesting and widespread theory about where church got his inspiration for the kidney pool. Skateboarding came to my neighborhood at the end of the 1980s. We got a little bit of magazines and videos coming from the California scene. Part 3. Finland. A redroffman actually went to Finland.
“你是怎么得到那些加州滑板手视频的？”“第一批视频是当有人去美国出差时带回来的。”扬内·萨里奥在芬兰长大，看着加州滑板手的视频，他深受感染。他开始滑板，后来获得了赞助，并开始在世界各地的城市滑板。通过滑板，我爱上了建筑和设计。
How did you get those videos of the skaters in California? The first ones came when some was dead, went to a business trip to states and then they brought back some videos. Janna Sario grew up in Finland, watching videos of California skaters, and he caught the bug in a big way. He started skateboarding and then became sponsored and started skating in cities all over the world. Through skateboarding, I fell in love with architecture and design.
扬内上了大学学习建筑，部分原因是为了能更好地控制他滑板的空间。“我会溜进那个建筑，不会告诉任何人我是个滑板手，只是确保扶手可以滑，或者楼梯有好的材料和曲线。”在建筑学院，扬内清楚地记得他听过的一场关于腰果形游泳池起源的讲座。
Yana went to university and studied architecture, in part to have more control over the spaces he skated. I'll just like sneak into that business, and I won't tell anyone that I'm a skater, and just make sure that they hand railing skateable or the stairs have a good good materials and curves. In architecture school, Yana distinctly remembers a lecture he heard about the origins of the kidney pool.
“有一位来自加州的教授。她做了一场讲座，谈到了唐内尔花园。我想她说它是所有腰果形游泳池之母。”但这在扬内看来似乎不对。他知道另一个腰果形游泳池。“它实际上是所有游泳池的祖母。它在芬兰，在芬兰中部。它是由一位建筑师和设计师设计的，
There was a professor coming from California. She was having a lecture and talking about the donor garden. I think she was saying that it's the mother of all kidney pools. But that didn't seem right to Yana. He knew about another kidney pool. It's actually a grand mother of all pools. It's in Finland, in the middle of Finland. And it was designed by an architect and designer
名叫阿尔瓦·阿尔托。”阿尔瓦·阿尔托的作品和生活在某种意义上是卓越的，因为他是跨学科思维和设计的先驱。这是安蒂·阿拉瓦，建筑师兼阿尔托大学副校长，该大学以阿尔瓦·阿尔托命名。他设计了精美的家具，而且他还有着蓬勃发展的业务。阿尔瓦·阿尔托是芬兰的传奇人物。
named Alvar Alto. Alvar Alto's work and his life was exceptional in that sense that he was a pioneer in a cross-disciplinary thinking and design. This is Auntie Alava, an architect and vice president of Alto University, which is named after Alvar Alto. He designed a marvelous furniture, and also he had a flourishing business. Alvar Alto is the man in Finland.
到处都有他的半身像。他设计了赫尔辛基的许多公共建筑、政府大楼和会议厅。而且阿尔瓦·阿尔托的家具，我不骗你，几乎在每一栋建筑里都有。几乎每个家庭都有阿尔瓦·阿尔托设计的东西。阿尔托不仅在芬兰受到爱戴和尊崇。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特喜欢阿尔托，但他讨厌其他建筑师。
There are busts of him everywhere. He designed a lot of the public and government buildings and meeting halls in Helsinki. And Alvar Alta's furniture is in, I kid you not. Almost every single building. Almost every home has something designed by Alvar Alta. Alta is beloved and venerated beyond Finland too. Frank Lloyd Wright loved Alta and he hated other architects.
弗兰克·盖里也称阿尔托是他钦佩的少数几位建筑师之一。阿尔瓦·阿尔托是建筑师中的建筑师，他的作品帮助创造了一种独特的芬兰美学，这是发展独特芬兰身份的重要组成部分。因为芬兰是一个相对年轻的国家。好吧，芬兰先是作为瑞典的一部分约500年，然后作为俄罗斯的一部分100年。加州有些电影院
Frank Gary also sites Alto as one of the only other architects that he admires. Alvar Alto was an architect's architect, and his work helped create a unique, finish aesthetic, which was an important part of developing a unique, finish identity. Because Finland is a relatively young country. OK, Finland was first for about 500 years part of Sweden, and then for 100 years part of Russia. There are some movie theaters in California
比芬兰还要古老。直到1917年芬兰才独立。在此之前，它是俄罗斯的一部分，看起来也确实如此。赫尔辛基市中心的建筑出人意料地庄严而令人生畏。建筑像高耸的粉彩蛋糕一样排列在街道两旁，带有白色的华丽装饰。赫尔辛基曾在多部电影中
that are older than Finland. It was only in 1917 that Finland became independent. Before that, it was Russian, and it looks like it. The architecture in downtown Helsinki is unexpectedly regal and intimidating. The buildings line the streets like towering pastel cakes with white ornate trim. Helsinki has stood in for Moscow and Lenin grad
充当莫斯科和列宁格勒的背景。在19世纪末，建立我们自己的民族认同并争取独立变得非常重要。芬兰想要摆脱苏联的浪漫主义，尤其是因为欧洲其他地区正在尝试一种称为功能主义的新方法。功能主义是对19世纪肮脏、污秽、污染严重的城市的一种反应，那些城市充斥着额外的装饰、饰品和雕像，而功能主义就像是一次建筑清洗。
in a number of films. And at the end of 19th century, it became very important to create our own national identity and try to get independent. Finland wanted to step away from Soviet romanticism, especially because the rest of Europe was experimenting with a new approach called functionalism. Functionalism was a reaction to the dirty, nasty, polluted cities of the 19th century, which were loaded down with extra trim and ornaments and statues, and functionalism was like an architectural cleanse.
功能主义追求健康。建筑之间有充足的阳光。空气清新。想想德国包豪斯那种锐利的线条、钢铁和金属，或者勒·柯布西耶那种纯净的混凝土。功能主义是干净、几何、严谨、宽敞、现代，而且有点冷淡。
Functionism wanted to be healthy. There was a lot of sunlight here between buildings. It was fresh. Think of the sharp lines and steel and metal of the German Bauhaus or the pristine concrete of Lecobusier. Functionalism is clean, geometric, stark, spacious, modern, and a little sterile.
所以阿尔托受到功能主义思想的影响，但想要将它们人性化。采用这种国际影响并制作他自己的版本。阿尔托的建筑干练且实用，但更自然、更有机。他部分通过大量使用木材来实现这一点。他让木材以以前从未有过的方式表现。以一种新的方式弯曲和粘合。这是乔纳斯·蒙德伯格，阿尔托基金会的建筑师和艺术史学家。“我们在哪里？你能描述一下我们在哪里吗？”
So Alta was influenced by functionalist ideas, but wanted to humanize them. Adopting this kind of international influences and making his own versions of that. Alto's architecture was crisp and functional, but a little more natural and organic. And he did this in part by using a lot of wood. He made wood behave in ways it hadn't before. Bending and gluing in a new way. This is Jonas Moundberg, architect and art historian with the Alto Foundation. Where are we? Can you describe where we are?
“当然，这是阿尔托自己的房子，办公室也设在这里。”乔纳斯向我展示了阿尔托制作的一些椅子和凳子的腿，并谈到了阿尔托弯曲木材的专利方法。这种方法使阿尔托能够制作弯曲的模具，从而制作出他成名的波浪形玻璃花瓶。“它是用木模吹制的。我们得到了不同且新的形状。”曲线进入了阿尔托的楼梯和墙壁，
Sure, this is Alo's own house, and also the office was located here. Jonas showed me the legs of some chairs and stools Aldo had made, and talked about Aldo's patented method for bending and curving wood. This method allowed Aldo to make curvy molds to make these wavy glass vases that he became famous for. It's blown in the timber mold. We get a bit different and a new shapes for it. Curves made their way into alto stairways and walls
他制作了弯曲的隔断来分割空间，并使用了圆形的瓷砖和起伏的台面。所以可以说，他制作很多曲线只是因为他能做到？就像他弄清楚了怎么做，然后他就……“可能吧，是的，是的。而且他可能想要那些。他希望建筑能成为某种你无法真正预测的东西。”
and he made curving partitions to break up space and he used rounded tiles and undulating countertops. So it was a fair to say a lot of the curves he just made because he could. Like he figured out how to do it and he was just getting... Probably, yes, yes. And he probably wanted those. He wanted the buildings to be kind of something that you can't really predict.
所以当一位名叫玛丽·古利克森的艺术收藏家和木材商请阿尔托设计她的乡村别墅——米雷亚别墅时，阿尔托希望它保持非常严谨和干净，但也非常友好和自然。“我们那里没有任何昂贵的材料。地板上只有木材，墙上有红砖，我们没有任何时髦的材料。”
So when an art collector and lumbererist named Marie Goulixon asked Alta to design her country home, the Villa Myria, Alta wanted to keep it very stark and clean, but also very friendly and natural. And we don't have there like any expensive material. Just timber in the floor, some red brick on the wall, we don't have any material that would be posh.
“但在芬兰，如果你要拥有一座乡村别墅，你肯定会有一个桑拿房。这是我们芬兰人在乡村度过时光的一部分。这是桑拿文化。如果你要有一个桑拿房，你需要一个游泳池来降温。”阿尔瓦·阿尔托做了一个形状非常奇特的游泳池。“嗯，这是一种……嗯，也许像只袜子，你看到了吗？”“是的，是的，它有点像只袜子，
But of course in Finland, if you're going to have a country villa, you're going to have a sauna. It's part of our Finnish way of spending the time in the rural countryside It's a sauna culture. And if you're gonna have a sauna, you need a pool to cool off in and over alto Made a pool with a very curious shape. Well, it's the kind of reform. It's a bit of a, well, maybe a sock, you see it? It is, it is, it's kind of a sock
带有弯曲的末端。”故事是这样的，设计唐内尔花园的加州景观建筑师托马斯·丘奇在1937年和他的妻子贝齐去芬兰旅行。不知何故，他们找到了阿尔瓦·阿尔托在赫尔辛基的家和工作室的地址，然后就找上门去了。他们直接敲了门。建筑历史学家马克·特里维安说：“故事是这样的，阿尔托从浴室出来，邀请他们进去。于是托马斯·丘奇和他的妻子贝齐，以及阿尔瓦·阿尔托和他的第一任妻子艾诺，都非常投缘。他们成了好朋友。而且很有可能，阿尔托为米雷亚别墅设计的袜子形游泳池在托马斯·丘奇访问时就展示在他的工作室里。”
With curvy ends. Hmm. The story goes that Thomas Church, the California Landscape Architect who designed the Denel Garden, went on a trip to Finland with his wife Betsy in 1937. Somehow they found out the address of Alvar Altos home in studio and got themselves there. And they just knocked on the door. Architectural historian Mark Trivian. When the story goes, Altos' home in studio and got themselves there. And they just knocked on the door.
“米雷亚别墅是在39年完工的，但他们是在37年去的。也许它当时就在绘图板上，也许当时还没有游泳池。我的意思是，我们只是不知道。没有办法核实。但这就是建筑师们讲述的故事。如果有一本关于唐内尔花园的书，它很可能会提到米雷亚别墅。”“是的，故事是这样的，托马斯·丘奇回到了家，那是1948年，当唐内尔花园建成时，距离那次访问已经过去了近10年。然后唐内尔花园的游泳池变得出名，出现在杂志封面上，并启发了南加州各地的数百名模仿者。而这数百个弯曲的仿生游泳池在70年代的干旱中干涸，激发了全新的滑板文化。那种文化启发了像扬内这样的世界各地的孩子开始滑板。而滑板启发了扬内成为一名建筑师。现在他有了专长。”
Architectural historian Mark Trivigan. When the story goes, Altos came out in his bathroom and invited them in. And so Thomas Church and his wife Betsy and Alvar Altos and his first wife, I know, all really hit her off. And they got to be good friends. And it is quite possibly the case that Altos' design for the Villa Myria and its sock-shaped pool were displayed in his studio when Thomas Church was visiting.
“是的，我是芬兰唯一的滑板公园设计师。”他在欧洲各地设计曲线优美的游泳池。专门用于滑板的游泳池。赫尔辛基东区即将建成一个大池子。这是一个非常好的形状。我想，这是值得骄傲的事情。当扬内说他感到骄傲时，他的意思是公共滑板公园和滑板池应该成为公民自豪感的来源，特别是在芬兰，扬内喜欢开玩笑说，
Myder was finished in 39, but they were there in 37. Maybe it was on the drawing boards and maybe there was no pool at the time. I mean, we just don't know. There's no way to verify it. But that's the story Architects tell. If there's a book about the Donnell Garden, it's probably going to have a mention of the Villa Myria. Yeah, the story goes that Thomas Church went back home, then it was 1948, and when the
现代滑板运动起源于芬兰。“当我和滑板公园建造者在一起时，我经常把它当作一个笑话，他们通常来自美国或加拿大，而我试图声称滑板运动起源于芬兰。”有人说，阿尔瓦·阿尔托在米雷亚别墅的游泳池灵感来自于芬兰湖泊的柔和弯曲。或者也许阿尔托只是对他制作波浪形形式的能力感到兴奋，因为这成为了他的标志，
Donnell Garden was made, so almost 10 years after. And then the Donnell Garden Pool becomes famous, appearing on magazine covers and inspiring hundreds of imitators across Southern California. And these hundreds of curvy, biomorphic pools get emptied out in the drought in the 1970s and inspire a whole new skate culture. And that culture inspired kids around the world like Yana to take up skateboarding. And skateboarding inspired Yana to become an architect. And now he has a specialty.
以及他的家具和家居用品。或者谁知道呢，也许他受到了世界上其他地方我们不知道的某个弯曲游泳池的启发。阿尔托不喜欢谈论他的灵感。他也没有写太多关于它的东西。阿尔托只用一个延伸的比喻谈到了他创意的诞生，关于溪流中的鱼。
Yeah, I'm the only skate park designer in Finland. He designs curvaceous pools all over Europe. Pools exclusively for skating. There's one big pool coming to the east side of Helsinki. It's a really nice figure in. And something to be proud of, I think. When Janis says he's proud, he means that public skate parks and skate pools should be a source of civic pride, especially in Finland, where Janis likes to tease.
“建筑及其细节在某种程度上都是生物学的一部分。也许它们就像某种大马哈鱼或鳟鱼。它们并非生来就已完全长成。它们甚至不是出生在它们通常生活的海洋或水域中。它们出生在距离家园数百英里远的地方，那里河流汇聚成细小的溪流。正如鱼卵发育成一条成熟的鱼需要时间一样，我们世界中所有发展和结晶的创意也需要时间。”干杯！你会需要这个的。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，德莱尼·霍恩编辑，斯里维乌西夫混音，肖恩·里亚尔和梅洛迪姆配乐。
Modern skateboarding began. I kind of use it as a joke when we're out with skate park builders, they're usually from states or Canada, and I'm trying to claim skateboarding for having its roots in Finland. Some say that Alvar Alta's pool at the Villa Myria was inspired by the soft bends in a finished lake. Or maybe Alta was just excited about his ability to make wavy forms, since that kind of became his signature
我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。其他工作人员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎，以及我，罗曼·马斯。感谢本周的迈克尔·伯内特、马克·罗德里格斯、杰森·雷特曼、克里斯·芬金、亚当·李、查尔斯·伯恩鲍姆和文化景观基金会、旧金山花园设计师加布里埃尔·卡梅伦、大卫·刘易斯和阿尔托大学，
and his furniture and homewares. Or who knows, maybe he was inspired by some other curvy pool, somewhere else in the world that we don't know about. Alto didn't like to talk about his inspiration. He didn't write too much about it either. Alto only talked about the birth of his ideas in an extended metaphor, about a fish in a stream.
特别感谢安德鲁·诺顿激发了这个创意。档案音频来自范德比尔特大学档案馆和1978年的电影《滑板之王》，你可以在YouTube上找到。如果你还没看过斯泰西的纪录片《狗镇和滑板少年》，我其实有点嫉妒你。它真的很棒。你会喜欢的。
Architecture in its details are in some way all part of biology. Perhaps they are, for instance, like some big salmon or trout. They're not born fully grown. They're not even born in the sea or water where they normally live. They're born hundreds of miles away from their home grounds, where the river is narrow to tiny streams. Just as it takes time for a speck of fish spawn to mature into a fully grown fish, so we need time for everything that develops and crystallizes in our world of ideas. Cheers! You're gonna need that. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Trouffman, edited by Delaney Hawn, mixed by Sriviusif and music by Sean Rial and Melodium.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心广播街制作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注我们。但如果你不去我们的网站，你就没有获得完整的《99%隐形》体验。网址是99pi.org。
Our senior producer is Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the staff includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Since you're gratitude to this week to Michael Burnett, Mark Rodriguez, Jason Reitman, Chris Funkin' Adam Lee, Charles Bernbaum and the Cultural Landscape Foundation, San Francisco Garden designer Gabriel Cameron, David Lewis, and Alto University,
来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and special shout out to Andrew Norton for sparking this idea. The archival sound was from the Vanderbilt University Archive in the 1978 movie, Skateboard Kings, which you can find on YouTube. If you haven't seen Stacey's documentary, Dog Down and Z Boys yet, I'm actually kind of jealous of you. It's really good. You're going to enjoy it.
特别感谢安德鲁·诺顿（Andrew Norton）激发了这个想法。档案音频来自范德比尔特大学档案馆1978年的电影《滑板之王》（Skateboard Kings），你可以在YouTube上找到它。如果你还没看过斯泰西（Stacey）的纪录片《狗镇和滑板少年》（Dogtown and Z-Boys），我其实还有点嫉妒你。它真的很棒，你会喜欢的。
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you're not really getting the full 99% of visible experience if you don't go to our website. It's 99inipi.org. Radio to pee.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Radio Row制作。你可以在Facebook上找到我们的节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@romanmars，关注节目@99pi，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注我们。但如果你不去我们的网站，你就无法获得完整的99%隐形体验。网址是99percentinvisible.org。99%隐形。
From P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。